les premiers slogans des gazolines beat
occupe a été
bit tout court habite tout court
d'accord
occupé ça a été rajouté par les gazelles
Marie-France bienvenue sur le plateau de
Tout le monde en a parlé alors vous êtes
né à Oran le 9 février 1946 votre mère
qui avait déjà eu deux garçons rêvaient
d'avoir une fille donc pour elle vous
étiez Marie-France dès votre premier cri
Maryse je devais être Maryse alors votre
mère vous coiffe et vous habille comme
une poupée jusqu'à l'âge de 5 ans en
fait ce qui a pas dû être pour rien dans
ce qui vous est arrivé par la suite
j'imagine je pense que ça devait être
une évidence pour elle parce que tout le
monde dit zéro quel joli petite fille
vous avez tout ça donc votre père était
cheminot et vous avez une enfance
modeste et heureuse avec votre mère
votre grand-mère vos deux frères et
votre père alors votre père il était un
peu un peu rustre et violent macho de
base
alors dès votre plus jeune âge vous avez
attiré par le monde des femmes les
poupées les maquillages les cheveux
longs mais en fait vous ne pouvez pas
assouvir ce penchant au grand jour quoi
il y avait un traumatisme c'est certain
des maps plus tendre enfance il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas dans ma
vie et ça allait de moins en moins bien
d'ailleurs et c'est vrai que j'étais
attiré par les par les par les femmes je
dessinais que des femmes et puis il y
avait aussi Saint-Laurent qui qui qui
débutait et qui glorieusement à Paris
dans la haute couture qui était oranais
comme moi donc c'est vrai que alors vous
dites à l'école j'ai aussitôt ressenti
que j'étais à part j'étais complètement
à l'écart des autres à l'époque vous
rêvez de Brigitte Bardot de Martin
Caroll qui sont un peu vos idoles quoi
alors à 13 ans en premier flash amoureux
un prof de 6e qui lui a 28 ans qui
ressemble à James Dean il vous embrasse
ils veulent aller plus loin mais vous
vous débattez dans un cinéma
et moi j'en tremblais et de désirs et de
peur
la seule à qui pourrait raconter tout ça
c'est votre grand-mère qui compatit en
fait
alors le 1er avril 1960 vous tentez de
vous suicider avec un mélange
d'octalidon de fenergon et de mort aura
tout ça parce que votre père vous avez
engueulé sur un carnet de notes non
c'est vrai que un moment donné nous
habitions Alger à ce moment-là et
j'avais trafiqué mes carnets de notes et
le directeur l'avait vu avait prévenu
mon père et mon père m'a être chaud
comme il était quand il recevait les
résultats de l'école c'était la ceinture
par qui je commence comme ça donc
il a pris très très mal il m'a gifler il
m'a demandé de rentrer dans ma chambre
et de ne pas dîner et là je me suis dit
j'en ai assez de cette vie c'est plus
possible c'est pas pour moi ce monde
n'est pas pour moi définitivement pas
pour moi je veux mourir tout de suite
et voilà
c'est vrai parce que c'est que vers 23h
on est rentré tout à fait par hasard
dans la chambre et on a vu que j'étais
verte et pleine de bave et complètement
crispé et là tout le monde s'est
interrogé on a fait venir une ambulance
et là il a fallu faire un lavage
d'estomac enfin dramatique les médecins
leur dis soyez très cool avec elle
si elle peut partir en vacances
faites-le etc et mes parents la bonne
idée de m'envoyer à Viroflay chez vos
cousins et là vous découvrez Paris vous
découvrez Saint-Germain-des-Prés j'ai à
peine 14 ans mais je fugue l'après-midi
en rusant énormément et je prends le
train j'arrive à Gare Saint-Lazare au
gare Montparnasse et je marche et je me
retrouve à Saint-Germain-des-Prés et
voilà quand vous revenez en Algérie en
fait vous êtes un petit peu différente
évidemment et vous rencontrez des
camarades comme vous avec qui vous
faites des virer dans les bars de Para
raciste là je rencontre des des
créatures il y a un peu hystérique à
Alger
très sympathique qui était plus âgé que
moi mais qui me prenne un petit peu sous
leur aile et donc je l'ai su un peu
partout et je me retrouve dans les bars
de parachutistes et à l'heure du
couvre-feu on se met à hurler dans les
rues alors que tout le monde est affolé
nous on crie de joie de bonheur je ne
sais pas on est heureuse on s'amuser
bit tout court habite tout court
d'accord
occupait par les gazelles
alors là la guerre d'Algérie oblige
votre famille à s'installer à Paris
votre premier boulot dans un salon de
coiffure rue de Maubeuge et le samedi
soir vous découvrez évidemment les
boîtes de nuit le fiacre le Bilitis chez
Michou alors voilà d'un seul coup vous
êtes chez vous quoi vous vous dites je
suis pas tellement différente de ça
finalement j'avais déjà compris depuis
mon premier voyage à Paris
j'avais compris que qui avait des gens
qui voilà que Paris était la ville où je
pouvais me réaliser et voilà il y avait
des gens qui me ressemblaient et qui
avaient un petit peu la même trajectoire
que la mienne et ça ça m'encouragé
beaucoup alors à partir de 1964 vous ne
vous habillez plus qu'en femme vous
devenez Marie-France vous dites Marie
comme ma mère et France comme la comme
matière promise quoi comme ce beau pays
oui la France me faisait rêver et moi
dans mon petit quartier perdu d'Oran
avec les bombes de tous les côtés tout
ça quand je me voyais dans la presse des
photos sur aurorant et un petit peu tout
ce qui s'y passait c'était c'était
l'échappatoire alors à cette époque là
vous commencez à vous habiller en femme
et vous ne deviendrez une femme au sens
propre du terme qu'en 1985 à Londres
vous dites un matin nouveau je me
réveillais dans une rose c'est joli non
oui oui
en fait je me sentais très fan déjà je
n'ai pas eu besoin de d'attendre cette
rectification chirurgicale pour me
sentir plus femme simplement
c'est vrai que pour moi c'était un grand
pas en avant quoi c'était le bonheur de
voir mon corps comme comme je l'avais et
puis voilà me sentir libre déjà rêvé
d'aller nu sur les plages et puis de
voilà bon voilà on est au milieu des
années 60 et là vous découvrez les
joints pas avec n'importe qui puisque
c'est en compagnie de Keith Richard et
Anita panamberg qui était sa compagne je
me retrouve dans leur appartement de la
rue de l'ambre dans le sixième
et je fume je fume ces cigarettes
c'est pas mal quand même oui mais c'est
votre copine Horla qui s'y colle vous
vous faites rien de sexuel ce soir là
moi jusqu'à jusqu'à
ma rectification j'ai eu beaucoup de
problèmes de ce côté-là avec avec les
amours passagères j'avais toujours des
garçons dans ma vie mais il fallait
qu'il accepte entièrement pour rester
avec eux mais comme ça rencontrait un
garçon et faire l'amour avec lui ça
m'était impossible tandis que ma copine
elle était pas ça ne l'a jamais pas du
tout alors voilà 20 ans donc vous êtes à
Paris vous faites la fête tous les soirs
vous devenez l'égérie du Jimmy's la
boîte de Régine au club 65 vous
rencontrez coccinelle le premier
travesti célèbre en France qui vous dit
tu es la nouvelle Coccinelle la
coccinelle dans le vent extraordinaire
oui c'est très beau c'est très joli ce
qu'elle me dit c'est et c'était en même
temps une investisseur incroyable pour
moi parce que j'avais 17 ans alors le
club Saint-Germain vous séduisez Nino
Ferrer
entre autres oui il s'est passé quelque
chose avec lui oui je crois qu'on a
passé une nuit ensemble
d'accord et alors vous séduisez
également Serge Gainsbourg qui dira plus
tard à bambou elle est la seule avec qui
j'ai trompé Bardot pas mal oui c'est lui
qui m'a séduit parce que moi j'étais
comme je disais toujours très timide
très réservé mais c'est lui qui ne me
quittait pas des yeux c'est lui qui est
venu vers moi qui m'a d'abord invité à
déjeuner c'est lui qui est revenu me
dire tu ne veux pas venir boire un verre
avec moi très gentiment comme ça moi je
j'ai craqué il était tellement élégant
et doux c'était Gainsbourg c'était pas
gains alors en revanche avec eau nazi ce
que vous avez rencontré chez Castel il
se passe pas grand chose
non pas mettez vénal c'est vrai que les
hommes ne m'ont jamais attiré et même il
y a eu il y avait un blocage d'ailleurs
il y a toujours un blocage avec les gens
qui qui ont de l'argent c'est incroyable
parce que vous refusez pratiquement une
aventure avec un oasis et quand vous
partez il vous donne 5000 francs pour
payer le taxi quand même c'est pas mal
bah oui parce qu'il voit qu'il peut rien
il peut rien avoir de plus
donc ben voilà ça se finit comme ça mais
en fait si j'avais voulu j'aurais pu il
était vraiment à genoux à mes pieds
alors voilà c'est en 1969 que Jean-Marie
rivière vous engageait l'Alcazar dont
vous ferez les grands soirs après avoir
dansé toutes les nuits pendant plusieurs
années et ne rien faire du tout et un
jour je me suis dit il faut quand même
que tu te décides peut-être de faire
quelque chose et la seule chose que
j'avais envie de faire c'était d'être
sur scène en 1972 vous fréquentez le FHA
le front homosexuel d'action
révolutionnaire et avec cette bande
d'artistes excentrique vous fondez les
gazolines donc vous traînez de
vernissage en fait branchée en hurlant
donc bit au cul pailleté on est bien
d'accord voilà c'était ça et puis arrivé
dans des dans des réunions très très
sérieuses où les gens se prenaient la
tête à parler sur des sujets graves et
là elle rentrait elle criait
donc évidemment on a été très remarqué
alors là vous créez votre spectacle en
Maryline et c'est l'apothéose c'est
vraiment le succès vous êtes à la fois
la star du Paris de la nuit et en même
temps la star des intellos branchés un
peu des cadences vont rencontrer Tiné
qui vous donnera un rôle dans barroco
vous tournez pour arrietta vous montez
sur scène pour Frédéric Mitterrand voilà
à quoi c'est Frédéric Mitterrand qui me
fait faire mes premiers pas au théâtre
et puis ensuite Marguerite Duras aussi
quel a été la réaction de vos parents
quand vous avez commencé à connaître
cette célébrité justement
mes parents mes parents étaient très
inquiets pour moi parce que parce qu'il
savait que c'était un une vie un peu
marginale je n'avais pas de papier je
voilà mon père mon père était comme ça
donc il fallait que je sois la sécurité
sociale que j'ai des papiers ils
comprenaient pas que je puisse vivre
comme ça pendant toutes les années où
j'ai fait des expériences qui ont duré à
mon goût trop longtemps ça a été comme
ça avec mes parents
réagissent comment ils sont un peu
bluffés mais en même temps bon eux ce
qu'il est ce qu'il est fascine ce qu'ils
auraient voulu c'est de moi me voir
arriver avec ma voiture mon appartement
être déjà mais bon il voyait bien que
c'était pas ça j'ai toujours été une
petite chose comme ça un peu
trimballé alors comment réagit vos
frères
mais de France ça va mais de France ça
va parce qu'ils ont bien un morflé aussi
avec mon père donc
vous avez découvert l'homosexualité en
fait oui donc ça vous a rapproché
j'imagine quand même un peu mais non
parce que non parce que vous savez c'est
pas parce qu'on est homosexuel qu'on est
qu'on est brillant et vos amis comment
ils ont réagi devant ce succès mais j'ai
toujours été aimée par parler par les
gens à Paris par mes amis toujours été
très très
supporté vos relations avec les médias à
l'époque c'était pas facile parce que
les médias étaient fascinés par par ma
personne par contre la seule chose qui
qu'il disait en parlant de moi c'était
toujours ce que moi je refusais qu'on
dise à mon sujet c'est-à-dire
travesti transexuel et tout ça moi
j'estimais que quand j'étais au théâtre
on devait parler de l'artiste et non de
voilà on n'avait pas besoin de parler de
sexualité
vous avez gagné de l'argent à cette
époque
non pas énormément non non non mais j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais vraiment manqué
d'argent mais non non j'ai pas beaucoup
gagné d'argent est-ce que cette
notoriété vous a amené à beaucoup de
rencontres amoureuses est-ce que d'un
seul coup vous avez été encore plus
dragué qu'avant oui j'ai toujours été
très courtisé mais mes amours je les
trouvais seul quel était le meilleur
moment de cette époque
bah si l'amitié quand même c'est
l'amitié c'est la fête c'est les gens
qu'on que qu'on voyait tous les soirs
c'est aussi à chaque fois des projets de
théâtre ou de cinéma qui me qui me
comblait de bonheur voilà c'est ça c'est
ça mes meilleurs moments et le pire
moment c'est à force d'expérience elle
est trop loin dans dans les dans les
drogues et me retrouver mal me retrouver
mal foutu et remonter la pente à chaque
fois ça c'était terrible
pétards avec Keith Richard mais après il
y a eu les en fait il y a eu les
membranes
à l'hôtel Louisiane et me disait il y a
une nouvelle canne qu'il faut essayer et
on me sortait de la poudre et des
seringues des trucs et puis c'était à
l'époque c'était festif
plusieurs vous allez sortir incroyable
je dois avoir
un ange gardien une petite étoile
alors là bon il y a des époques plus ou
moins bonnes en 75 vous en êtes réduite
à faire des strip-tease dans les dans
les foires avec Takita Paquin ça c'est
quand même une époque non c'était un jeu
ça m'amusait énormément mais c'est vrai
que en même temps ça me faisait mon
argent de poche alors là vous restez une
égérie de l'underground notamment à
l'occasion de vos concerts au Palace
grande époque Fabrice emere avec les
branchés de l'époque vous faites partie
de la bande de Louboutin Pierre et
Gilles pacadies et vaillonnesco Edwige
vous êtes vraiment dans la bande du
palace quoi voilà et c'est peut-être pas
un grand succès public mais vous avez
beaucoup de succès chez les branchés
de toute cette époque
pas vraiment non non non pas vraiment
mais je n'ai rien oublié
si c'était à refaire Marie-France
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
je ferai beaucoup moins de bêtises et
je ferai moins de d'expérience et voilà
je toucherai moins à ça j'ai perdu
énormément de temps
énormément de temps j'ai perdu des
années j'ai raté des opportunités
incroyables de travail des propositions
magnifiques puis j'aurais fait aussi mon
changement plutôt
beaucoup plus tôt ah oui parce que à
partir de ce moment là je me suis sentie
tellement bien dans ma peau et j'ai pris
la vie avec une sérénité jusqu'à lors
inconnu
le jour où vous allez mourir qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on écrit sur votre
tombe
si j oui là Marie-France chanteuse et
artiste
au revoir merci j'étais très heureux de
rallumer la lumière soit vous merci
beaucoup Marie merci et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu